I think it'd be incredibly challenging
to take somebody who's never done real
estate recruitment for example and put
them in a new market because they have
no understanding in terms of recruitment
real estate how they can create value
for people welcome back to another
episode of the recruitment mentors
podcast I'm your host Tisha mizzouz and
on this week's episode I was joined by
Julian Adams from McDonald and Company
well that's how you start to build up
credibility and then again that sort of
feeds into both the candidate side of
things and the client side of things and
last year he became the top performer
within his company where he built just
over one million pounds within the year
as a perm recruiter within the real
estate market so in this episode we
uncover exactly how he did that how he
consistently sold retainers to achieve
that goal how he took his career to the
states which was absolutely pivotal his
business development strategies the
importance of building candidate Talent
pools and how to go about that and so
much more enjoy the episode
Jillian welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me
looking forward to this we've got to
know each other a bit I know you listen
to the podcast I know a bit about your
journey because we've been you know
speaking over the last couple years
so I'm looking forward to you know
dissecting taking a bit of a step back
and talking about the last five and a
half years because I think
uh yeah from learning about your story I
think it's a great one
and really looking forward to everyone
you know learning about it and and
everything that you've learned along the
way
so before I see the million dollar
question let me just give everyone some
immediate context some career highlights
the Show reel
um so if anything you know I'm missing
you let me know but you know from
preparing from this uh what I draw down
here is start your recruitment career as
a 360 recruiter in November 2017.
that's when it all started
uh first five six months was a real
struggle
I think you said to me that you did
around 13k in your first five six months
but your first year Billings ended up
around 111 Grand
second year Improvement 215 Grand
third year 260 Grand another Improvement
and this is all in the UK Market in the
regions
in the fourth year you started this U.S
Journey
as you just said in your bedroom if
you're in covid so March 2021 and ended
up that fourth year doing 616 Grand in
sorry 616 Grand in your Billings and
that was American Market from the UK
moved to April uh sorry move to April
moved to America in April 2022 but in
your fifth year Financial year which uh
just uh finished you uh hit the 1
million pound Billings Mark which is now
is a big goal of yours
um and now I don't know we'll see what
happens sixth year right in terms of
that that continues in that trajectory
so you know I think just to frame this
up a lot of people have been sold the US
recruitment story
you're living proof that you know this
is something that can become a reality
for people because a lot of people being
sold what you could potentially achieve
in America so really excited to dissect
this with you specifically around you
know BD gain interaction adapting to the
market pitching retainers that I know
has been a big part of your story to all
of that but let's just start
what are your thoughts on you know the
characteristics and trades that you
believe make up a highly successful
recruit in today's market and then we'll
start from there
yeah of course
um
my general thoughts are is it's
intangible characteristics such as being
passionate or competitive I think a two
for me
um
spent a lot of time really trying to
look at different people in McDonald's
and Company and the group and really
seeing what they do well and then trying
to replicate that and really sort of
pushing yourself to drive and compete
with people uh I know I've not everybody
has the sort of competitive feeling but
I think just the
when we're looking at hiring people we
typically call it the the why or the
fear and you really need something that
is deep inside you that drives you to go
and perform every day what drives you to
get out of bed and make today's a
successful day
um
I've seen it from both sides of things
in terms of people who we've taken on
who haven't really been as passionate or
haven't really had
the motivation from inside them in terms
of you know it can be anything from came
from hard times when they grew up
through to you know they've got a kid
they want to provide the best life for
them uh through to they're just Money
Motivated and they want to be successful
so I guess it doesn't need to be
a particular reason you know in one
bucket or another it just needs to be a
reason that drives the person on yeah um
I've seen people that have not lasted
very long in recruitment because they
don't really see it as a as a career in
something you can be really successful
in so the brilliant the intangible ones
I think in terms of passionate and
somebody who's competitive I've got that
drive within them
uh and then let's just talk about this
for a secular how how obviously you
clearly it's important but how
how much of an emphasis of importance
would you say that is to you know your
own story and your own performance over
the last five and a half years how how
important has that been for you
PK yeah key to it
um
I think I mean I think it's probably a
bit of a detriment in the I'll beat
myself up and push myself to the point
of probably breaking to try and compete
with people and to try and uh be number
one
but that's probably what's going to be
successful and allowed me to get to
where I need to get to so that coupled
up with you know working relentlessly to
get to that point
um probably the key driver or the key
the key piece to the success
okay
so let's just break this down a bit so
just really quickly for people listening
let's just talk first part of this
journey
um just just some frame out for people
you know so your world you can describe
it to me like you know the world that
you recruit in
is permanent like could you just give us
just a real high level flavor of you
know the what do you recruit and the
types of um companies and industries
that you operate in and I'm gonna you
know go into the questions but I think
that'll be important for people because
immediately people will be thinking okay
well what Market is this guy recruiting
what's his average deal size all that so
just give us a bit of a flavor on that
on when he was in the UK and then yeah
we'll we'll go from there
sure so doing the same thing in the UK
as I'm doing in the US now we're a real
estate Specialists so working across
development investment and asset and
portfolio management also other areas in
terms of some financial pieces so
looking at Capital markets and investor
relations roles for Real Estate groups
as well the main groups we're partnering
with are real estate developers and
investors and that can be anything from
uh on the investment for a family office
through to an Institutional Investor
different investment funds so that's
really the the market that we're working
within and in terms of asset classes is
a real range so because we're real
estate Specialists we understand
different nuances and intricacies around
different asset classes so we've got a
real range of coverage there
and then um and then let you you can
create them if I'm wrong here but so in
in the UK you you wasn't in the London
Market which you was doing the regions
right
correct so Birmingham North Birmingham
North annual average deal size of
between five and six grand
yeah probably some yeah five to eight
probably five to eight yeah cool
um and then look and then let's just
frame hours really quickly then what's
ended up being an average deal size in
the US because if you said you've pretty
much been doing the same type of skill
set same thing but in the US what does
that ended up looking like in the US
uh probably somewhere 30 to 45 000
um that's probably skewed a little bit
in the uh I'm a bit greedy so I'll work
low level roles as well if we'll if
they'll retain us for them so they'll
probably skews it somewhat but I think
generally the the average probably would
be around 50k okay cool perfect right so
that just massively out so let's just
you know start with this like just just
initial period right
struggled at the beginning
you know
um like a lot of people do you know
looking back at that period and then
we're going to really go into you know
what changed what you did differently
how you've continued to you know improve
not stagnate you know looking at those
first five six months you could have
easily quit right
uh did thank the first six months but
then uh clearly then had a better finish
to the year so you know what what was
you looking back what was Julian doing
wrong in those first six months you
think
good question
um
I think it was going back to the point I
mentioned earlier I think it was the
real desire and actually understanding
the opportunity that I had
um
I came for myself background with Harley
Davidson doing their insurance and
candidly that was uh it was just a bit
of a bit of a laugh it wasn't really a
career
um moved into recruitment because I
wanted to scale up what I could take
home and I had a few friends who'd gone
and done that and
I think I was just at the point where
it was probably just a job for me you
know it wasn't it wasn't a career
um and I also think that generally
there's a there's a Runway where you
typically give yourself six months for
everything to click and fall into place
and you know the initial stuff that
you're putting out people then start
remembering you and going back to you
and so on so you're trying to learn
um sort of different markets you're
recruiting in as well as the the skill
set of recruitment so that was probably
the sort of Runway to to get up and
running how uh how old were you
uh how old was I 23 yeah okay yeah Fair
there's still very much like you know is
this one okay and I'm doing
not too bored if it works out doesn't
work out you know that's fairly normal
so when when did you start to get a
sniff of like hang on a minute
this is actually something that you know
I could
earn some good money changed my
circumstances you know because it
doesn't just happen overnight does it
like you start to you know
how like realize actually you know I've
got a great opportunity here when did
you start to get a sniffer that do you
think
going a little bit anecdotal there was a
there was a candidate interview that I
did and I met a guy for a coffee in
Manchester and we talked about different
roles that he might consider in
different groups and we mentioned a few
of the smaller groups that are in the
same space as what he does and he's
going to mention to me you know I
wouldn't go and work for another smaller
groups because it's not as appealing I'm
one of the best groups that do this type
of work now
um and he likened it to the work and the
opportunities I had with McDonald and
Company where he said you know you
wouldn't go and work for you know insert
large corporate group or smaller shop
you know you're you're with the best
group of people
um
I think I mentioned this to you on the
on the sort of prep for this but
um I actually ended up placing that
candidate it was my last placement
before moving to America and I still say
to him to this day you know I I really
do owe you
um I do quite a lot because that
conversation was the the real sort of
driving piece for me where everything
clicked and I thought you know I've got
a phenomenal opportunity here to be
successful so I really don't know
so if that clicked just casting back to
this period I understand that sometimes
you know it takes a third party someone
out of your typical Circle to go you
know look you've got a great opportunity
here or you know to give you a different
perspective
um so I totally understand that but just
if we can get into that frame of mind
you know you just had this meeting it's
just clicked you've gone hang on a
minute yeah I've actually got a great
opportunity in front of me I'm
surrounded by great people
um I could really you know make
something of this
uh what was the first thing that you
know you did differently when you got
back at your desk what were some of the
things you started to do differently
um
it was just our mindset change you know
just it was like the cogs turned it's
like
let's work harder than anybody else
there was I had a really great setup in
Manchester in the the guy that runs the
office you know I obviously I can't
thank him enough as well
um but he really sort of integrated the
knowledge and the the sort of
foundations of recruitment for me
there's a guy who was the second person
on that desk and he's a phenomenal
recruiter he is just a machine and so he
was really The Benchmark for me talking
back to the competitive piece that was
the guy and I was like okay he's killing
it at the moment that's where I need to
be what is he doing how do I scale
things up and go from there so
um really just finding those uh the I
guess the intrinsic desire to to want to
better myself and want to compete and
you know what's this in far away at that
point
you know we've got one way to do this
yeah and then and then just on there
just to focus on this for a second a lot
of people listen to this will have those
people in their team in their
organization but not everyone will
maximize that
so you know you just describe this
person clearly inspirational clearly
someone you can learn a lot from like
you know what what did Julian actually
do to extract some of that value to you
know like pick up some of the things
that this person's actually doing you
know there's one thing seeing them
seeing them at the top of the
leaderboard or whatever but like what
how what was your actual attack to you
know actually extract some of the things
that you can learn from this person you
know did you say hey look I'd love to go
for a coffee and ask you a couple of
questions did you I don't know ask to
listen to some of his calls like what
what does that actually look like how
did you approach that
well because we're in such close
proximity in the office you could you
could have a haircut anyway but it'd be
asking him questions around this client
or why I think this candidate is
suitable
um
and then again it's it's just the uh
just to bang on about the competing
piece and uh
really driving yourself I'll go
anecdotal again
um whenever I would get into the office
if he had found new clients on a system
I would look and I'd be like you know
where have you found those guys from and
he told me it was from one of the sort
of marketing pieces that is shared
regularly within real estate in the
Northwest and so I got to the point
where I was checking that out sort of
pretty frequently but
you get to the point where you check it
in the afternoon and you see there's a
new client on there that's just moved
into Manchester for example and you go
on the system and the CRM and he's
already put them on so then it's like
okay so
I'm on the right lines of things to
scale things up
but how'd I beat him so then it came to
the point where I came to the office
before him and the first thing he does
every day I know is check out that
publication so I'm not doing that and I
know that if I don't get in it early
enough to
um you know review them map them out put
them on the system and do my BD email or
I'll reach then he's going to have them
so he's my biggest competition both
inside and outside of the company
um so really looking at the people
that are being successful and that are
doing well within the industry and
trying to replicate what they're doing
and pushing that a little bit harder or
trying to get ahead of them and get any
sort of advantage that you can yeah now
great share and then anything just on
that tangent is there anything else that
you know you you sort of latched on to
quite quickly could be you know on the
candidate side it could be when
headhunting people could be managing a
process could be you know on the the BD
speakers the client side was there
anything else that you found you know
you latched on to and it really worked
well for you as well besides uh that
from this person out of Interest
um
it's not really sort of um rocket
science I think I think the key thing is
just speaking to as many people as
possible asking
more detailed questions
um to better understand the market and
to connect the docs I think the real key
piece and we'll we'll talk about this a
little bit later on in terms of the BD
side of things but in terms of
connecting the dots and being able to
leverage information from one person to
the next that's how you start to build
up credibility and then again that sort
of feeds into both the candidate side of
things and the client side of things
yeah okay
nice so
let's let's just sort of gear up then
towards the us because I feel like that
that's been quite pivotal for you right
I mean you're going through some real
life changes you know personally and
professionally you know it's it's
exciting so let's all talk about this
window because look safe to say like
leading up to the USPS you know you was
on the upwards trajectory working hard
improving year on year
um which is what I'm hoping you know
you'd be really happy for what he was
aiming for but then it looks like you
know particularly from the performance
wise
like what what initially gave you the uh
inspiration to look at you know the us
or even consider that because you know
you did the the UK market for three
years and then it was this fourth year
where you know there's this huge spike
in your actual overall Billings
performance so first you just talked a
little bit about when did you know the
USPS initially sort of feel like
actually this is actually something that
I'd consider
um and why was you considering it
so we'd would flow to the idea around
about opening the US business for for a
little while before bringing the guy on
that set everything up there
um
and really was just sort of growth and
and
um upward trajectory I think the
I don't said achieved everything that I
could in Manchester because I got a
pretty easy life we've got a lot of
we've got a lot of the markets sharing
the regions in terms of what we do and
so I probably could have sat there and
you know not to be arrogen but put 250
300K in every year yeah and been happy
but that was really the the ability to
scale things up further in terms of you
know building out a team having
something that started from scratch that
can present Real ownership and
yeah just just take over take over sort
of uncovered land yes I did just new new
opportunities
out your comfort zone something
different okay so
so just so we understand then so uh the
strategy was uh middle and the company
hired some um uh experience to open that
up and then uh you uh was someone that
I'm guessing put your hand up or you
know put your hat in the window you know
what this is actually something that
really excites me so was the initial
plan okay Julian look that's something
that we're excited by too let's give it
I don't know a year period or whatever
the time frame was where you're gonna
work the US market from the UK is that
typically how it went down or what the
sort of you know initial sort of high
level plan was
yeah not far off
um I sort of made it known that I was
interested in the role um and then when
they got to the point of bringing the
guy on
um had a couple of conversations with
the CEO and also the guy in the US
um and we all felt like it would be a
good fit uh
I don't know whether it was their plan
to see whether I was successful from the
bedroom in Manchester or not
um it was right at the point where
Donald Trump had had the travel ban on
the UK US Travel piece so we couldn't we
couldn't fly to the US because that was
absolutely in place
um and the embassy also had a massive
backlog on these replications so it was
it was at the point where we were seeing
how things were going but yeah doing it
from the bedroom in Manchester wasn't
wasn't that fun so just so you know the
timeline when did you make your first BD
call to a us-based real estate company
like when what month was that and what
year yeah April 2022 April Twitter well
okay I'm sorry 2021 yeah April 2021 Okay
cool so that's the timeline right so
we're pretty much yeah so we're that's
two years right so firstly you can be
honest of us you know was there a plan
you know was there you know was there
some sort of plan on because the US is
huge what state we're going to
go after we're going to focus on you
said obviously you know you're going to
cover the same specialisms uh be known
for similar things that you run in the
UK but you know was there a high level
plan on how Julian is going to you know
go to market from his bedroom in uh
Manchester well what was the initial
plan
so of the point where we've brought the
guy in America he had sort of a
six-month Runway until we
pivoted across to the US market yeah um
we have no appetite whatsoever to look
at California an appetite to look at New
York we were going to be Texas driven
and then sort of wider Sunbelt and um
the rocky mountain region with a lot of
work in the midwest
um
candidly that probably wasn't it
probably wasn't that clear of a strategy
to be honest I think we we knew we'd had
a great track record we've obviously got
a fantastic brand in terms of offices
all around the globe and so it really
sort of played into
um kind of sharing our track record in
different locations looking at groups
that we've done work with on other
continents and then also trying to build
up relationships with some of the local
players yeah
um to Alex the guy I work with in in
America his sort of Testament uh he did
a fantastic job of initially
uh building up some truck record from
scratch for us when when he first sort
of came into the company
um
we were we were working things in in all
locations from you know Knoxville which
don't know whether you know much about
Tennessee but there isn't uh there isn't
tons gone in Knoxville and then you've
got the the hardest requirements that
somebody wants we're still finding we're
still finding the people so
um we started to build up a truck record
and then
probably over that first 12 months it
again
being a bit greedy we picked up stuff in
different locations and then as time
went on that transition to you know let
zero in on a certain Market or have
people designated to different uh
geographies
okay yeah sure no I understand like you
know part of you know part of Journeys
like this you have to there's
experiments there's risks you have to
take there's bits you have to make and
then once you know make some of those
bets have some of those experiences you
know you can then refine learn from and
become more um focused so just with the
early stage uh in mind
I guess there's a lot of people
listening to this that you know might be
in the trenches right now All-Star
you'll know you know you obviously
there's still so much for you to do and
potential and growth but you know you're
you're more out the other side here you
know you you build more of this track
record you've had a ton of different
experiences so if we just focus on that
initial period like you know know what
you know now knowing what you've learned
from uh obviously your peers and and the
US
um uh Team like if you were to go back
to that moment of starting this American
journey in your bedroom in Manchester
what would your first 90 days look like
what would you prioritize
you know what what activities would you
be prioritizing what would you be doing
I think what are the most important
things to for us to be doing in those
first 90 days you think
um first of all you need to build up a
candidate pool because
yeah if you haven't got any candidates
to work with you're going to really
struggle to
um to pick up work
um
you know
picking up vacancies or opportunities
with certain groups and then trying to
drop interest or just trying to find a
reason to better understand
um
what these people are looking for and
also better understand
what groups are competitors to these
companies
um
one thing which trigger I'll sort of
come around to it with the BD piece but
in terms of one thing I was typically
doing on every call to better understand
the market every candidate that I read
at the end of the call I would ask who
would be the top two or three companies
that you want to work with or you would
work for in a heartbeat and if you think
you're doing 10 candidate calls a day on
the light end it's an extra 20 to 30
clients that you can business develop
with a warm lead an additional to that
you're also building up your market
knowledge which I think is imperative to
again be successful to win work to have
good quality work yeah no that's a
really smart question so really double
down on building your calendar day
candidate talent pool uh really get to
grips with you know who are some of the
best known Brands companies that people
would love to to work for
and that would be a really good start
um I guess you know just quickly as well
and I want to sort of wash you some uh
questions on this BD piece but how long
did it take you to do your first deal
uh
uh June I think uh sorry at the end of
May we have that Knoxville role I
mentioned to you will replace that at
the end of May but that was something
that Alex had teared up that I was
working on with him so uh my first deal
that I picked up the placement started
in June yeah
okay because I think people also you
know as you can imagine listening to
this probably thinking you know I'm in
the trenches right now
I'm maybe doing some of the things that
Julian is saying but I'm not you know
I'm struggling to find traction you know
what from your experience I know it's
only one experience but what do you
think would be a good time frame from
what you've picked up so far and you
know the journey been on what do you
think would be a good time frame of if
we're doing the good work we're doing
you know the right activities to give
you know the us or that sort of um part
of the world Affair opportunity well
yeah you know six months long enough I
don't know
um in terms of if you're talking about
going into a new market how long you
think it takes until you you really
start to get traction there's another
question yeah sorry I could be a bit
more clear so just more of like you know
like I might be sitting here right now
and I haven't really gained any
attraction I'm a month in to you know
trying to you know take what I'm doing
in the UK but then into the US like how
long do you think I should at least give
it for me to be able to look in the
mirror and go you know what I gave that
a fair crack maybe there was a potential
there you know I don't know if you have
any thoughts on that
as long as it takes there's always
potential right
um nice I know that's probably not the
answer that that you wanted in terms of
the time frame
um I think look if you got to the point
of four weeks and
it all depends on what you you sort of
quantify as traction if you built out a
really great candidate pool within
whatever Niche or area it is that you're
looking for you can always do things
with those people and
ultimately and I listened to a few of
your podcasts prior to this to do some
prep a lot of people talk about the long
game and I can't stress that enough that
you know everyone wants to make a quick
book now right but long term the
conversations that you're having day to
day are going to impact what your future
looks like and just treating people the
right way and making sure that you come
across credible whether it's a candidate
or a client you may not get something
from them day one but you know in two
three months or in 12 months time they
should remember you from
a lot of the other people who probably
aren't as credible or aren't asking the
right questions or adding any value
um
but yeah I think I think you'd look at a
four week period and try and
not to sort of zero it on kpis but look
at the traction that we've had
um I think three months to try and get
some form of placement given the notice
periods of two weeks rather than you
know four to twelve weeks
um
and yeah just just I guess try and set
out the goals as to what you're trying
to achieve outside of fillings by way of
building some sort of truck record or
building UPS
um
relevant candidate pool or client bull
go and then just a couple other things
they just if we're just to you know just
zoom in on the beginning period and then
we'll go into what you think you double
down on what you did really well some of
the strategies that worked so like some
people might be thinking Okay so
sit in my bedroom in Manchester London
wherever going to the US market
I don't I might have had some success in
the UK now we're going to go into the us
so you said that what would be
fundamental would be speaking to
candidates building that talent but
obviously that's absolutely crucial
right
so uh why as a candidate am I going to
give you my time if you haven't got any
track record in the US
you're someone in the UK calling me like
what I don't I don't understand why
someone in the UK is calling me you
haven't got any jobs to talk to me about
like you know what like when we're
speaking to these candidates like what
what why should they give you your time
like why what value can you give them
what is it that you is leaning into
because you know you're you're trying to
build something so you haven't unless
you uh tell me otherwise what are some
of the things that you had to offer and
and why would these people give you
their time
good question
um
I think I think around the sort of value
piece for these candidates it's really
sort of having some form of truck
records somewhere and at least
understanding the market you're
recruiting in
um I think it'd be incredibly
challenging to take somebody who's never
done real estate recruitment for example
and put them in a new market because
they have no understanding in terms of
recruitment real estate how they can
create value for people
um
another look at a lot of it is
persistence you know there are still
people now with two years in still
people who aren't that familiar with us
I think that we built with a track
record but there are still people that
we've you know hit on LinkedIn and put
phone calls into still we haven't had
any traction with us spoke with them and
so again it kind of goes down to the
persistence piece and the value that
you're trying to create is as I say to
everybody whether it's a sort of junior
level analyst through to the CEO or CIO
of a company
um everybody could use a good Headhunter
within their Rolodex or within their
contacts and so even if we're making the
initial connection now and there isn't
something to talk to the candidate about
in terms of a role what you can do and
you know to this point I had a couple of
conversations earlier where a couple of
guys I spoke with weren't relevant for
the role I was working on but we want to
make that introductory conversation
number one from your side because you
can pick their brains and get better
knowledge on the market and also you
know are they actively applying for
things if so what companies are looking
um but also you are
building a warm introduction so the next
time something does come on in six
months time but it's relevant you can
pick the phone up to that person they
should remember you if you've done your
job correctly
um
and then it makes it a lot easier than
just sort of a cold call uh you're just
trying to get the person's interest
because you've already spoke with them
um
another answer that completely oh yeah
no that's fine look I think I think this
would be helpful for people just quickly
like what does that actually look like
you know like let's say we're reaching
out these people on LinkedIn I
understand what you're saying you know
you said about some of the things that
you know we want to try and portray that
look may not be able to help you now
however look I've got this track record
I'm confident that you know at some
point I'm not going to introduce to
someone that might be really helpful in
your career I might even be able to you
know speech about
um a job opportunity that could be you
know really positive for your career I
understand that but you know would you
mind just sharing with us you know early
on like what does that actually look
like what does it actually sound like
are you saying on LinkedIn like hey look
building a market here would you be
against giving me five minutes your time
confident you know
um I might be able to tell you at some
point if we're trying to get that across
on the message you know what what does
that what does that actually sound like
what do you actually lead with you know
via you know on LinkedIn or on the phone
like what does that actually sound like
um
I think I started out with with one
development role in in Dallas and so
that was the starting point really in
terms of
reaching out to people and trying to use
that as leverage
um
I think it's challenging I think you
would get shut down a lot more if you
went with the angle you suggested there
in terms of you know we're trying to
build a market out dominating at the
moment but can we can we connect
um so really trying to sort of mention
or even try and get another hook in
terms of there are tons of great groups
that we're working with at the moment
I'd love to just pick your brains or
hear a bit about what you guys are doing
at this company
um and then again I mean it's really
looking at some of the traffic record
we've had in different locations and
being able to talk to a couple of the
global groups that we work with and then
you know dropping some of their names
um I wouldn't say everything that's
probably
Right Down the Line in terms of you know
you hear about an opportunity maybe
you're not working it but you're sort of
suggesting to that candidate that you
know we know people at that company or
we're familiar with some of the work
they do and so again you're probably
doing a little bit sort of Faking it
until you make it in terms of trying to
just get interesting get the ball
rolling with candidates
um so I think really it's looking at
potential roles that you may have or
groups even laboratory different
location and sort of suggesting that you
do some work with those guys just to
build up that track record and then it's
a bit of a cycle then one start once
that starts going and you've got
candidates coming to you and obviously
then sort of winning other work
and then just on this just to progress
this a bit so I know we're going into
the detail here mate and that's all
right tonight I I understand what you're
saying so like then let's just say we're
on the call
how are we approaching that you know are
we saying you know we worked with these
types of companies we haven't got
anything on at the moment you know are
you just owning the fact that you know
you don't have all these live vacancies
I know you wasn't saying that that's
what you're saying as to like why they
should give you time but like as well
what are you saying on on these phone
calls you know I mean are you just
saying that we work with these types of
companies
um and these are the types of you know
firms that will likely be picking up
jobs with and then you're sort of
continuing that message rather than
because some people might be worried
about oh I might get on the phone call
they're going to say right tell me about
this job then or tell me about that man
how God didn't work on that job
but you can easily objection handle that
in terms of you know saying that you're
partner with X group you don't need to
mention a company if somebody asks you
about the role you can say we haven't
spoke before it'd be eager to sort of
understand your background understand a
little bit about what you're doing
um
you know can you give me some color and
I'm more than happy to tell you about
the group depends on the level of role
so and again you need to you know I
think whenever we're trying to go into a
new market and trying to
build things up you you always have the
ability to use a trapdoor to get away
from something you know it's a role that
my colleagues working on I'll get more
color for you can I take an email after
or you know I really want to understand
your experience better because if you're
doing X asset class then it might be
relevant for this and so
um I don't know where short I'm talking
about it the other piece that is
valuable Mr candidate is the
this isn't going to be the opportunity
that I'm going to bring to you there are
going to be other things in the future
so whilst I've got you now we've made
time to set up this call and eager just
to
run through in more detail what your
background looks like what would be the
kind of thing that you would want to
move into what would be the kind of role
that you'd want to go for and again if
you then go to the point of you know I
don't know how well people will
appreciate this um this example but if
you've got a development manager and
they want to be a vice president of
development you could probably tell them
that the other role that you suggested
to them is probably more Junior than
what their expectations are so if I want
to tell you about that one but I'll keep
in the radar for the future
um so that's probably why I would do it
I think registering a candidate if they
try and give you challenges in terms of
who you're working for you always have
the ability to to sort of either use the
drop door or to step back and say you
know we haven't spoke before I'm eager
to understand your background and also
your aspirations motivations and what
you're doing and then I can provide you
with the best type of company to to sort
of work with or look up hey everyone a
real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry and
Source breaker because you listen to
this podcast you're able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincere who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products no no
I appreciate you sharing that and I know
yeah I think that'd be really helpful
for people
so I understand there's a bit of a
journey right you know like you said
you've got a not presume that you know
more than you actually do but you know
there's an element of you know you're
trying to be what you you you're trying
to be what you want to become right
before you become it that's just the
part of the game right
um so just as we're talking about this
early period and then let's go on to the
the BD strategies and you know how we
went on to achieve these types of
building performances
um you know looking at that early period
what what were some of it sounds like
you just went into it head first because
you're someone that's willing to learn
you've got the mindset but what were
some of the you know early challenges
maybe on the candidate side client side
I don't know that maybe you uh had to
adapt to didn't expect
example might be one of the ones I
picked up a lot on from speaking to
people is they had to learn the hardware
that Americans are really good at you
know being engaged and yet June sounds
great blah blah blah and they'll be like
that and then they just won't hear a
film and just get it completely ghosted
they said that happens a lot
um you know there's the the salary
conversation is slightly different a lot
of people you know you either can't tell
ask them all their salaries or they get
really weird about that so what are some
of the challenges that you found you
know you had to navigate in adapting and
you came up against
yeah
um
I think really it's learning the market
and knowing where to go you know where
to go fishing I guess
um really sourcing the right levels of
people and the right candidates
um I remember when I first started one
of the first contingent roles that I
worked on was for an investment
associate with an investment Fund in
Dallas and
it was my first sort of Crocket trying
to to build up the Dallas business and I
think I you know
went through Linkedin recruiter sourcing
people I think I've registered about 150
people in a three week period so yeah
every day was was long hours trying to
find the right people pivoting LinkedIn
certain ways to try and get the best
people
um interviewed all of those people and
then share probably our best 10 people
with the group and uh this as is the
case with some clients they're just
incredibly hard to please and so they
took a few people to final and then
didn't progress them and then decided to
put the role on hold
um
but obviously it's means to an end so
probably the success piece from that was
I ended up picking up another investment
associate role a week later sent my best
eight people and got that job turned
around within a week from shortlist to
offer and acceptance
um
I don't really know about the people not
coming back
um with Americans I I think that is an
American thing where they are
you know incredibly polite and friendly
on the call but they probably won't be
as direct to tell you that they're not
interested so I think there are a lot of
pieces around qualifying people and
again going back to asking difficult
questions or hard questions because you
don't know it's your time and you don't
want to chase people if they're not
interested
um
but yeah I'd probably say just learning
the market and trying to build up that
knowledge being the the sort of key
piece and the most challenging early
doors yeah nice
um man I appreciate you sharing that so
let us go into the the bdp thing because
you know you're not hitting the type of
numbers you are without consistently
bringing on
great client opportunities great jobs
that are fillable you know so let's just
talk a bit about this so you know you
can you can go into the past year last
year but if we were to talk about uh
Julian's business development strategy
uh-huh we've spoken about the importance
of you know the candidate uh Talent
pooling
um and not just having your candidate
hat on you're asking smart questions
like you know what one to three
companies would you love to work for or
you think are amazing that's obviously
you know you're building your Market
mapping there and you're building uh
companies that you can obviously go
after so obviously part of the BD
strategy is you know ask good questions
use the kind of conversation use
information to my advantage but what
else you know
um in this BD strategy uh for Julian
what else did it consist of what else
did you find you know really work for
you over the last two years
um
I mean I think everybody said this more
recently in the past 12 months just
given how hot the market was when you
were speccing out candidates you know
that was probably the main driver for a
lot of people
um
our aim our aim wasn't necessarily with
that piece to place that candidate that
was more of a tool to get a client on a
call who had a requirement and then we
would then pick up the work and go
through that process
um there are obviously tons of tons of
different routes into into BD whether
that's looking at different ad chases or
again leveraging candidates in terms of
you know where else are you interview
angle I don't want to make sort of
duplicate introductions so
um you know what would be yeah where
would you look at as a as a group and
how far along are you in those processes
and I guess trying to leverage them to
the point of understanding
who they're working with in those
processes whether that's a recruiter or
whether they're doing it all direct
um outside of that I mean you've again
cold calling pieces
um
I think with the whole cold call beast
and this was something I was discussing
with one of my colleagues earlier
um
people don't necessarily like to be sold
to so I think that really the key piece
one picking up the phone to various
individuals I don't like the idea of
somebody sitting Beyond a spreadsheet
and ringing one client after another for
100 calls because you can't have any
sort of value or build up any sort of
talking points for these clients so one
thing that we always try to do alongside
looking at
the target pool of clients we wanted to
work with was also if we are going to
try and business develop different
groups that we've picked up leads for
um looking at their website looking at
any sort of information on Google in
terms of the news or anything else to
see whether if they're doing development
they've got any project in the market
and relating that into the conversation
because people are talking about
themselves people like talking about
um
you know some of the stuff they're doing
into other accolades so it's really
trying to show you've got market
knowledge and credibility and then
talking to those pieces and trying to
take the conversation from there I think
a lot of the time people will get a
little bit displaced with trying to
build rapport with someone going to call
when they didn't really want the call
initially they probably don't care that
you've got a dog called bubbles they
don't want to tell you about their dog
they're not interested in any of that
what they want is to better understand
what you've got going on what you know
is going on in the market and people
love free things right so whether you
then present them at some point with
salary benchmarking or Intel on the
market or what the competitors are doing
um but it's really trying to strike up a
chord with somebody with useful Intel
opposed to
how's your weekend mate you know what
are you what do you do do you watch the
football but they're not interested
they're busy people
um so looking at different routes into
into sort of starting a conversation
that way
so it sounds like uh Showcase in Canada
is pretty pivotal like that that was a
big part
yeah initially I mean um trying to Speck
out good quality people
um and then as soon as we sort of got on
the call with them we could talk the
track record and requirement and qualify
the job properly and then position
ourselves though we wanted to because
that works in the last six months
as well I mean I sold three retainers so
far this month and I've been on holiday
for a couple of weeks and uh the same
last month so
it's it's been slower the appetite has
been slower in terms of the responses
from specs but again the you know
probably a luxury point where well I
could pick and choose what work I picked
up and so if I've got a bandwidth to
service it then I can and if not then
um yeah you know somebody else can pick
it up I guess we're gonna go into the
retainer piece but just clearly that
that's been you know a really important
tool on everyone listen to this we'll be
specking out candidates
regardless if you like it or not so many
recruiters will be doing it some
recruiters do it great some recruiters
not so great for me wife when we say not
so great I just feel like it's just
super unpersonalized it's you know send
out however many emails not even
thinking about the person receiving it
and I'm sure they'll be if we send it to
enough people there'll be people coming
back right and I do feel like that is
definitely one of the activities and
habits that you know does a good job of
tarnishing our reputation
um you know let's talk about how does
Julian approach Becky like what does
that look like what is a good spec from
General are you calling me and you know
you've got your picture you're going hey
look I haven't spoken before
looks like you've got some good projects
on the go despite this investment
associate person at the moment who said
that they'd love to work for your
organization uh look don't happen uh to
know if you know you have anything going
on at the moment or you know are you
mainly emailing people what your
principles to doing exceptional specs I
actually get responsive to
um
a combination of those pieces so
first of all
they need to be you know one thing I
think sort of thought worth talking
about is looking to build out your
day-to-day so making sure that it's
clean in terms of coding people with the
right
um sort of code skill level competency
um because yeah I'm sure you know the
track record of people sending out specs
for completely irrelevant candidates
it's not gonna be very high I'm sure in
terms of return
um so really looking at different asset
classes and then also different
competencies and trying to book it
people that way it means we spend longer
in terms of trying to Pivot all of that
data and making sure that we're not
hitting the same people
um you know with sort of multiple stacks
and also
um
just just making sure it's relevant is
at least in the right wheelhouse there's
nothing worse than obviously receiving
something unsolicited where
it's not even relevant to you you don't
really put a good
account of yourself in terms of those
people receiving those sorts of emails
so really looking to splice it and make
it relevant to however many people
you're trying to hit
um
additional to that picking up again
going back to the piece about
trying to get information from
candidates if you know that there's a
hiring manager in a certain company and
you've done a similar search or you've
got good candidates that cover the same
thing that they're looking for then
obviously you can tailor it much more
directly to that individual
um but honestly just given the looking
at the US market given the amount of
people and just how broad it is
um
it is too challenging to try and splice
absolutely everything and just you know
dump it down to the point of putting 50
to 100 people into a hot list because
that'd be a full week and nobody's got
time to do that
um I also typically like to anonymize a
resume to go on there or a CV and the
email should not be incredibly wordy in
detail because people just delete that
should be pretty brief and to the point
probably two sentences
um I think that typically gets more
attraction than doing a bit of a
write-up on the email as well so well
100 bro two sentences what might that
sound like
um you know first name uh enclosed here
is the resume of a talented development
manager that I'm working with
they're currently doing industrial
projects within the DFW Market if of
Interest let's set up a call yeah super
Direct
yeah because at the end of the day you
can ask where you bought sorry if you
don't want to waste your time you don't
waste their time if they like the look
of that resume they're going to get on a
call with you or they're going to show
interest
um if they don't otherwise mess around
then you're just not interested your
time is very valuable yeah and clearly
this has been one of the most effective
ways for you to open doors and then
consult getting them on the call all of
that
yeah exactly laugh so all right cool so
let's let's move this on to return we're
going to go a bit over the hour mark
here but that's fine with me if that's a
cool review because I think there's more
there's more to dissect here so okay so
what what I want to know then because
you should share it with me uh share
this with me on on the prep call
was
going into you know the year that you
just had you shared with me that you
know you set your size on you set your
eyes on becoming the top Biller
then she then went on to achieve right
which is where you've hit uh you know
over the uh just over the million uh UK
pounds Mark within a year so first what
I'd love you to just share is how did
you make sure you wasn't overwhelmed by
that because like did you know that
you're going to have to build something
around the million or you know what
being the top Builder what was like the
initial figure that you knew you had to
get in and around
um
I thought it'd be high hundreds of
thousands so there's a guy who
um was sort of competing against for the
last few months and he's been the top
builder for the past you know four or
five years since I joined the company we
joined at a similar time all that he has
a lot more recruiting experience
um and as far as I sort of would see it
he's like the The Goat in terms of what
he's been doing
um I think he finished last year on like
825 000. sorry Matt did the year prior
yeah
um so I figured it would be high yeah
500 thousands maybe a million but
um I wasn't I didn't really have a
number inside I kind of thought let's
try and do a million dollars and see how
that goes first of all and then once we
got to that point it was like okay let's
see if we can do a different currency
yes so so what I just love you to just
share because I think you know we
basically I guess what I'm interested in
is how you sort of broke down broke that
down because I find speeds a lot top
performers that this is what they're
really good at because you know you wear
you know so basically earned yeah 840 K
dollars in the fourth year so I guess
yeah
um it's an extra like 20 basically
you're like aiming for you know to get
an extra 20 out of what you did in that
first year in America right but you know
beginning of the financial Year we're at
zero no starting again
what like how did you break down that
Target a million dollars to make sure
that you because looking at that you
know write it down like how the am
I gonna do that you know it's a big
number so like what's been your you know
process to if you do have a process on
breaking that down so you don't become
overwhelmed by it and you know you you
focus uh it on chunks if that's
something that you do
I mean I'm always overwhelmed so
probably not the not the best question
um
I mean look it's just like taking
accountability at the end of every day
um you know I'll always check my my kpis
and my stats for the day to recognize
whether I've had a good day and and
equally sort of a good week and if
you're
it's like putting ingredients into a
cake right if you put enough of each
thing in it should turn out okay
um I didn't really have a certain number
that I needed to do each month it was
mainly a case of just working
relentlessly and honestly going back to
the competitive piece kind of keeping an
eye on anyone that was ahead of me and
just making the decision you know work
harder work longer just try and deliver
for clients and ultimately
you know it should work out okay
um and then obviously you get to the
point as we get closer to the running
where you're keeping an eye on what
they're doing and again sort of trying
to trying to push as much out as
possible in terms of
um Business Development picking up work
and then finding ways to try and service
that as well as trying to keep plate
spinning
so I think what people be interested in
is what what do those what were uh you
know Julian's uh key ingredients the
kpis what were some of those and they
might change in certain parts of the
year but you said that you know I'd look
at my key kpis and I'd be an indication
to me that you know I had a bad day
rather than a not so great day so what
are some of those key kpis are you
always looking at if I've registered
five candidates per day then I should be
on track or you know what were some of
the key ingredients
yeah so candle calls typically I mean
for 10 a day
um and that's irrelevant as well right
it's not a case of just registering
somebody that isn't really relevant to
what we've got going on or wasting time
on that client calls typically trying to
do two or three a day
um I mean my Spec's Target was
yeah in the thousands every month I
couldn't tell you what that was meant to
be but trying to get specs out
consistently
um
again good quality CV so a lot of the a
lot of the pieces around sort of BD
being a consultant to the group so
making sure every resume that we're
sending or every CV we're sending if the
client picked me up and asked me why
I've sent that person making sure I
could talk to the reasons why in my
thought process so sending good quality
CVS not just trying to hit a Target and
then obviously converting those to
interviews and again Consulting the
clients to if they're on the fence about
somebody the reasons why we should
consider having that conversation
um what would you aim for your CV to
interview ratio typically to be
probably two yeah yeah should interview
probably one in every two people
[Music]
um
it depends on depends on the group and
Depends exactly what they're looking for
but
um you know we're trying to put together
a short list of probably a people I'd
expect half to have the to get the
opportunity to interview
um another shortlist where I've shared
eight people and they've gone there to
interview six or seven sometimes all
eight
um which is sometimes great sometimes
you're thinking I don't really know if
you know what you're looking for because
it'll give you a bit of a range of
people but um yeah you know a large part
of the role is Consulting clients
through the process a lot of them are
hiring a certain individual as a new
hire that they haven't done before and
so you have to kind of work with them to
help find what they like and what they
don't like in candidates yeah so no I
know we're talking a lot about quantity
here but as Julian said if you're
listening I mean the quality is just as
important but I think what what
I love hearing here is we're talking
about
quality but also the quantity required
the inputs required to get anywhere near
the million Mark you know so we're
talking ten can they calls per day at
least two free crime calls per day I
mean you mentioned the number of
thousands of specs so uh you know good
number of of specs and like that's
really helpful for people you know
because there's a lot that you could be
doing you know if you're getting around
there and you're asking good quality uh
questions and you're using information
to Advantage then you know then we can
really be building traction and moving
forward
um June let's talk about this retain
Journey then
because you know you told me a lot of
questions yeah you told me last year
every single deal that you did was
retain right is that correct
correct yeah so talk to us mate because
the fourth year
how many how many retainers did you sell
in the fourth year
uh so I made some notes just for the for
the preps I saw 18 retainers in the
fourth year
um and did 42 placements in total so
um you know that was that was inclusive
of the retainers
um and then last year I did 58
placements and 33 of those were
retainers and there were a few still
yeah falling into this year so let's
just talk about this and you know we'll
talk about this and then we'll you know
wrap this up but so okay fire free
retainers who went from 18 to 53 to
doubled basically and then prior to that
you hadn't ever worked in that way right
I sold two in the previous three years I
sold two interview okay cool three all
right so then let's break this down then
right so okay let me first start I guess
a good question to start would be if you
sold two in three years and you sold 18
um in that fourth year
what the hell did that pitch sound like
when you sold two
compared to what it sounded like when
you sold 18. well what were the main
differences in that pitch if we were
sitting on that pitch on retained
um
I mean the the two that I had sold
retained had been existing clients
previously
um
it was more case of talking about the
time that I had to put into the
Searchers to to make it worthwhile so
again it was sort of nominal amounts up
front probably two or three thousand
pounds
um
and yeah I probably felt a little bit
cheeky asking for money up front
um
it certainly changed since then I I
guess sort of pivoting to now
um
really just just expressing the
my time is valuable I think that you
know it sounds incredibly sexy when you
talk about exclusively retained work and
everybody wants to do it the reason we
do it isn't because it's sexy or because
we can say you know I've got retained
jobs on
um
you really look at the contingent model
in the retained model and when you're
doing contingent work
that money is never guaranteed and so
typically what you see is
recruiters will pile themselves up with
as many contingent jobs as possible
they'll probably send three or four you
know low hanging uh learning through you
know candidates
um and then that probably doesn't get
that much time because there are other
recruiters working on it or they're just
not sure that they'll get a fee the key
piece around how we're positioning this
and why we're doing it isn't to get
money up front because that doesn't
really mean that much to us besides
commitment from the client it means that
we're working on an exclusive basis
where the ability to map out and vet
candidates properly is guaranteed money
so means that we can put as much time
into it as possible and ultimately build
out and provide the best shortlist to
candidates so that's the reason that we
do it because we cover our own back and
it allows us to do a proper job opposed
to you know I'll send four candidates
and somebody else will speak to one
person and built on them but it's just
not of interest and so it's really
having that mindset that
we want to do the best possible job and
consult to these clients and so we're
not just taking money off them and doing
nothing with it you work relentlessly to
provide results
so okay so let's just talk about this
then because I I think everyone
listening will go well there has been
nodding they're like yeah definitely
agree all these things right but all
those things that you just said
is how it helps you and your team
not because it's sexy not because you're
getting money up front but because your
time is then is is that you're actually
putting a value on your time and as you
said you can really commit to delivering
a great service but that's all the
benefits to you but obviously in order
for you to sell these consistently the
other person you're talking about them
has got to feel like okay well that
makes sense for me and my business how
that's going to help me so you know
let's just talk about let's just talk
about this process okay because you know
people might be like okay well how does
it how does this actually work is it
different is it not different we'll find
out so if you know I become a client
that you speak to about you know
um Pitch and return to
are there so what are the steps firstly
you know you might have sent me a spec
CV I've gone Julian this candidate mate
this is this is someone that I'm excited
by we get on a call yeah you know
talking about the processor we are going
to go straight into you know a bit of a
discovery call and then we're going to
book another call where we then do a
proper pitch on the retainer what what's
the typical sales process
no we're just we're just in one call
um one call and we'll go through yeah
yeah one goal okay if they want to do a
follow-up to understand terms or any
other pieces then then we can do that
um but I'll typically try and make it at
30 minutes or it might overrun
um slightly depending on the level of
detail we get into
um
over video
phone call no I don't know okay right
right let's break this phone
call down then come on because that's
that's surprising to me I'm not gonna
lie I thought there would be but this is
why I think this this is a helpful
people because I thought there'd be a
bit more to it you know you might put a
presentation together you might have
found that a bit more run you know about
their challenges their their pain points
but this is great you know because this
is unearthing you know people might be
over complicated in this stuff but why
don't you show us what is important that
happens on this 30 minute call
I think just to your point about the
they're probably being a lot more to a
video called presentation whatever
um
I don't think they really care like
honestly I don't think they really care
I think the key pieces that they want to
know are what does your truck record
look like does this person have the
right questions and understand what
we're looking for but also giving them
the confidence to
um you know but believe that you will
deliver for them
um in terms of the oh look up I'll give
you the example I play a lot of Poker
I'm not going to show you all of the
cards but uh yeah let's give you on the
Frameworks you know people listen to
this does it we want the Frameworks you
know what what are some of the key
things that you know we're gonna go
through yeah I mean definitely do your
do your diligence on the company first
of all take a look at some of the
material take a look at what they're
typically doing have a look at uh people
within the group to see whether you know
anybody or are familiar with them maybe
you've got some as candidates and so
you'll have insight into some of the
stuff that they're working on that you
can relay you know in the market about
the group
um and then look really I
I let them lead the call by way of do
you want me to give you a a background
on a MacDonald and Company or are you
familiar with us uh well why don't you
tell me about what you guys have got
going on you know why did this
development manager interest you what
did you have in mind for this person
um typically they'll give a high level
overview and
they'll probably go into as much detail
as they think is required I think then I
will talk to them on a much more
technical level in terms of different
pieces around the role and you know
probably make recommendations or
suggestions as to why I think would this
person fit coming from this background
or you know
um you share credibility with your
questions and you're on exactly yeah
yeah
and also talk to any sort of track
record or
um whether they know people another
company that you'll be familiar with I
think that's the key one in terms of how
close that a lot of these markets are I
think providing you can mention a name
and you could happily say to the person
yeah give give Dave a call now they'll
say great things about me
they won't call Dave but if you're
willing to be that sort of you know
brushing out there they'll probably
think okay this you know this guy
probably knows what he's doing
um so go into technical detail
understand the role better really deep
dive into the company's culture growth
trajectory really talk to the ability to
understand everything so that we don't
waste their time or our time and again
sort of talking through the the whole
candidate Journey piece because people
want to have good reputation in the
market and so and you also want to work
with groups that aren't going to dictate
underlays around and give you a bad name
um a lot of other pieces I think that we
sort of leaned on particularly through
covid would be our ability to manage
candidates expectations you got to the
point where you had three or four
opportunities per candidate you know and
you weren't representing them on all of
them so really sharing with the clients
that we manage our candidates closely
um the percentage that we typically lose
to counter offer or to another
opportunity was incredibly low and talk
around those pieces and how we do that
um then go into what I would like to
think is a very fluent or fluid uh
uh pitch of the company and some high
points around why we're specialists in
what we do talk a little bit to the
truck record
um I certainly mentioned on a on a call
the other day that they use pitch decks
or sorry I'm one of your podcasts yeah
they use pitch Stacks
um I think that's useful for people
um I've got a pretty good memory so I
usually know
competitors I can talk to in people and
people I've placed and so on so I'll
drop a few names there in terms of those
pieces and then I'll typically then ask
them you know do you want me to run
through what our contract looks like and
it's just you know straightforward this
is how much you pay upfront this is what
it looks like
um
you know we have cancellation Clauses in
all of our contracts as well so if they
don't make a placement obviously we'll
we'll charge a fee on top of that so it
is it's a real
um exclusively retained work a poster
just taking a little bit of money up
front and then kind of leaving it open
um
and then look I think the other piece
really is just trying to close them I
think the we've had this a few times
where some of our guys have done what
they think are really good calls but
yeah I've just sold retainer and then a
week goes by two weeks go by client
isn't going back to them so I think you
know providing they want to talk to it
you ask them around you know from the
contract
is there anything that stands out to you
there is there anything that you feel
uncomfortable with or you know what are
your thoughts on that
um
and there have been calls where I've sat
and talked through different parts of
the contract and you know where we can
probably add some flexibility or the
reasons that we have that in there and
how it's beneficial to them and it's
really making them feel comfortable with
what we're trying to do but again I
think they keep he's going back to it
it's just market knowledge and
credibility if you can talk credibly and
ask high-level questions and reference
people you know in the industry that
you've done work with then that's
probably as good as it's going to get in
terms of you know you should pay me
money upfront to do this because
I've I've done this search 10 times in
the past three months and
there are you know we've got pools of
people and and relevant bits I think one
of the thing and look I'll I'll
overshare here a little bit I think um
when people picture retained work
usually
there's always this emphasis that we
have to uh we have to bow down to the
client you know your company's great you
do all of this really good work
um
that often goes against people in the
you know they think all right well if
we're great we'll post it on LinkedIn or
you know you should be privileged
working with us whereas you have to have
the confidence in your mind number one
that they should be privileged to work
with you because of the value that
you're going to add but number two I
wouldn't say diminish what they've done
but I also think that you probably over
egg even though you've done this search
a few times you know you probably overag
that it is challenging because you know
there aren't tons of these people that
cover this area in the market so you've
got a small pool of people to work
through this is the reason that I think
that you need to build on this approach
because if I think it's easy why can't
they give it to you know another
corporate group that will do it for 15
and no retainer
um so it's really trying to
suggest that you have the ability to
typically work up and do it because of
your truck record but also you know not
fluff the client up too much to the
point they think ah this is going pretty
easy and actually they'd be really lucky
to work with us if you need it the other
way around
no I appreciate you sharing all that
Julian and look I think what what I
actually take from that and this is
something I always think about because
I'm always someone that's willing to
learn on sales and running to improve is
obviously there's so much power to
understand this it's often not what you
say about how you say it
so for me why I'd say it's not doing
this if I was listening into one of your
calls you know the way that you would
speak about McDonald's company or track
record how you work it would just be
with you know conviction you know
directness confidence
and this is how we work you know there's
no there's no element of like yeah like
it'd be like it'd be great if it could
work this way it's like this this is how
we work
it's like if you um if you wake up one
day and decide you want to go buy a new
car you go to the Mercedes garage and
you pick up all of the extras they don't
start saying to you oh well you know we
we like this white leather or the screen
leather that you've picked you know it's
it's gonna be twelve thousand dollars to
add that on the you know um well we can
we can try and move around like that's
the price that's that's what it costs
for what you want so if you want to do
this and do the right way then let's do
it and we could we can service it and we
can make it happen if you don't then
that's also fine just don't waste our
time
um yeah it's just having the confidence
you know this is the way that this is
the way that we're doing things and
if you want to try it out you know we'll
we'll do the work for you and there's no
problem with that if not completely fine
and then and then just a couple of bits
so typically when I speak to people how
they would structure this would be uh
you know and I know it might vary and
you might have some flex but as a sort
of core product core service typically
when I speak to people it's like you
know they'll uh ask for
um uh x amount of the you know uh
overall fee up front to come in uh to
sort of commence the partnership
commence a project and then it might be
oh it might be broken into third you
know then the next third uh might be
when uh you know you've presented uh a
short list initial shortlist and then
the other third would be when that
person is then signed a contract
are those typically been the same
Milestones that you've you know used to
uh break down your service typically or
so we don't split into thirds so we'll
have an upfront fee and then there'll be
a completion fee
um right
again I think that's probably another
piece that
depending on who it is you're pitching
to plays into your handle a little bit
and the you know some of these groups
could have paid out two-thirds of the
overall fee uh shortlist or interview
stage and they might not like any of
those candidates so they're already 66
out of pocket and the person's gonna
start again
um so yeah it's just an upfront fee and
then the completion fee
um with the retainer deducted off that
what was typically the average upfront
fee you charge
uh some of my clients are gonna be
disappointed probably uh
okay yeah nice and then somewhere in
that room do you not have any Milestones
you don't have any like you know agreed
Milestones like okay okay we'll commence
this and then by this period I'm gonna
probably give you this or is it not is
it just then we're going to go through
the process rest on the completion
to the restaurant completion I mean so I
get a bet for is I don't say it's easy
to sell retainers but it's you know it's
within the Wheelhouse and then the hard
work is finding the right candidates and
putting the shortlist together but again
talking about quality of resume shared
you should have it done in the first
sort of go and then your track record
comes into play right it's like look
typically this is what would look like
this is what we've done in the past
um honestly like I know the way this is
going to be really helpful for people
because you know I think a lot of people
can over complicate this and you'll just
owning how you work this is the best way
to work you know and everyone benefits
um and then on this because you know
everyone talk I'm sure you picked up on
this as well that everyone says you know
the fees are bigger than us you shared
it was the average deal size compared to
the UK but have you typically found
yourself negotiating better times as
well like what what's ended up being the
average little percentages that you
managed to negotiate in the US because a
lot of people say it could be 25 30 but
we don't know how true that is
uh
uh the higher end that you quoted and
higher is what I'll say all right sound
cool man I appreciate you over over uh
Sharon here right
um Okay so
oh I just wanted to share a text with
you
um which I think you might find
interesting from your good friend Nick
Carman he's a friend of the friend of
the the Pod right
and um he said he is without thou the
nicest guy you could ever hope to
outbill you
I'm not sure yeah I'm not sure I don't
know
um why why why would he why did he
describe it that way
I don't know man I don't know uh I
probably I mean some of the guys in
America probably think I'm I'm super
intense because when you when you come
in and you're locked in then you know
that's it we're to make money we're here
to to do the job but
um
I don't I always I will always try and
give people time or let's try and uh
trans chess and some gems of value be on
Nick's Nick's a good guy
um
how he how he grinds that work and who's
building so consistently without a pompo
ceremony always impresses everyone
around him
yes well that's uh
that's nice to her
um yeah like I say I I spent a lot of
time trying to
copy and I can learn from Nick and he
gave me some really good pieces in terms
of building out on building out the desk
and doing business development and so on
so
um yeah I couldn't I couldn't be happy
to have that sort of Praise from someone
that's achieved so much with McDonald
and Company
you know so look we've covered a lot in
this conversation people listening that
won the the US success story
what would be your your part and advice
my friend
um
work ethic just I mean it's the boring
one right it's the one that ever really
serves but if you ever look at anybody
that's been successful whether it's in
recruitment or any other industry you
know from sport through to anything else
try and do the try and do the best
possible job that you can for yourself
and for your clients candidates make
sure to act with integrity and advise
people because we're playing the long
game and uh there'll be conversations
that you have and I think that you
really need to
I think that you really need to treat
every single conversation as one that
you can get value from whether it's
today or in six months or in 12 months
because people will remember how you
conduct yourself and calls and in
situations so try and be um try and act
with integrity and more than I think
just also let's get it I love it
um look Julian been in absolute pleasure
kudos to you my friend you work ethic
what you've created
um what's uh what's the Billings goal
for this year my man are we uh what are
we aiming for
um conservatively 1.5 million dollars so
that's probably about one point
one 1.2 million pounds
um
there's some more juice we can squeeze
there's no
you know this for me I'm gonna be you
know what like you're not I think the
best way to view it is like you know
you're not playing a finite game you
know like you're paying you're playing
an infinite game like the the goal is to
keep playing at the highest level and
why put like a cap on anything you know
what I mean that's why I I'd sometimes
try and remind myself is like why would
you so I've capped it all out now you
know there's why wouldn't there be more
and not just better for you and there's
probably more that could be done
um
I don't think I'll mark it slowing down
I think as you continue to build
relationships and scale things up and
learn and get better the things should
continue to increase until I get to the
point where
you're just killing yourself and you
can't do it anymore
um
but yeah I think I just need to I need
one thing you didn't ask me which
um I'm awful at so thank you for not
time management and organization I'm
just I'm horrible at it so I probably
spend more hours working than I would
need to uh if I just plan things out
better so maybe that's going to be my my
success route to uh one and a half or
two million love it Julian thank you so
much
come on thank you so much for listening
to the episode I hope you enjoyed it and
got value from the conversation if you
did enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode